six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller let's try
the 732 area code and 732 has been a
tough one for us sometimes 72 is really
good and sometimes 732 is is difficult
so who's with us from 732 today hey it's
Kyle sorry I'll try to be better today
Kyle I was not talking about you that
I'm going to admit go ahead Thanks so
something I've been feeling recently
over the past few weeks since the tax
bill has passed is starting to feel like
maybe the scandals going on with the
Trump administration might be trumped by
you know perceived economic gains by the
voters and it's starting to worry me so
dirty way you can make me feel like
maybe people will actually go out and
vote for Democrats or get this guy out
in 2020 no I have nothing positive to
tell you unfortunately you're spot on
which is that listen people started
getting depending on your income started
getting a few more bucks in your
paycheck now whether you'll ultimately
end up paying a higher or lower
effective tax rate is going to come down
to other aspects of your economic
situation you won't know that though
until as late as April 15th of 2019
which will be after the midterm election
you do see even though
disproportionately
only the rich are really in the stock
market in a very significant way you
still see sentiment about how the
economy is doing tied up in the stock
market so we've had a big run-up and
that's been good but then we have this
pullback that could have been the early
stages of a correction or the beginning
of a mini recession we still don't know
but then it's kind of popped back up and
down its erratic right now and I don't
know that it's really impacting people's
overall assessments of how the economy
is doing we did have a report earlier
this week that inflation is starting to
tick up but if we're talking about
really small moves here so I believe
that just saying we did tax reform is
going to bring more benefit to
Republicans for 2018 then whatever sort
of nuanced repercussions any one person
can suss out from it and I share your
concern
yeah just to clarify though do you think
the voters will care more about the you
know the perceived economic gains from
you know whatever the administration
does in the next year or do you think
the scandals will really play on their
mind it's gonna depend on which voters
the trumpets are going to be more
comfortable ignoring the scandals by
saying hey he did taxes and I get an
extra 25 bucks in my paycheck whereas
more people on the Left are gonna say
hey wait hold on a second this was
mostly a handout to the rich and there's
20 other scandals going on so I think
it'll be have a very partisan effect and
after the independence then I'm sorry
the independent voters the swing voters
in 18 and 20 like they're gonna make a
big difficulty knows where they will go
it'll depend whether they're left or
right leaning but if the approval
approval for Trump remains low then
those independents could end up pushing
smart more Democrats in two seats in
November thanks for the call really
appreciate it good question I mean it's
good people are thinking ahead to the
midterms because that's that's an issue
that we we need to be talking about